こんちは！はじめしゃちょーです！
あの昔ですね
シャクレルプラネットっていうガチャガチャを回したと思うんですけども
こちらにあります
ワニとライオン、パンダとコアラと
・・・
ミーアキャットが当たりました
リアルで凄く可愛くてクオリティも高いんですけども
全員アゴが出ています
うん
素敵！素敵だよ！ホント素敵だよ！
今回なんと！
シャクレルプラネットの第二弾が出たらしいです！おめでとうございます！
あっ！あの静岡のガチャガチャのシャクレルプラネットは売り切れてました
売り切れるってどうゆうこと！
こんなただのあ・・・
こんな素晴らしいフィギュア・・・は売り切れます
売り切れます
こんな素晴らしいフィギュアは売り切れて当然ですよ
静岡に売ってなかったので
わざわざ東京に行ったタイミングで
秋葉原のガチャガチャが沢山あるお店で
そこで回してきました
そこに暮らす動物たちはみなしゃくれている
自らの顎を進化させることで絶滅の危機を乗り越えてきたからだ。
骨もバリバリ。木々もモグモグ。岩もバクバク
しゃくれるプラネット、それはそう遠くはない未来の地球なのかも知れない。
素晴らしい！
ひょっとしたら今の地球に住んでる動物たちも
我々人間も近い将来生きていくためには
アゴがしゃくれるかもしれない
それをこのフィギュアはもう最先端、先取りして
もう未来の姿をフィギュア化してしまったという素晴らしいフィギュアでございます
売り切れますわそりゃ
ひょっとしたらこの地球にもすでにしゃくれている人類がいるかもしれません
うわぁ！！！
クッ・・・・ぅ・・・
ッガ！！！！ハァハァ
なんだ今のは
脳内に直接語りかけてきただと
ッッン！！！
まぁいいだろう、まぁいいや
とりあえず６個あけていきます
1つ目！
1つ目は誰が出るでしょうか！
はい！
え、小さい
うわあぁぁ！！
ちょっと待って、待って待って待って
出ました！はぁい！！
うわ、うわぁ〜
うわうわうわ
ハリネズミですね
ハリネズミが出ましたがこの子も
アゴがしゃくれています！
ハリネズミですらアゴがしゃくれてしまいます
はい！というわけで１匹目はハリネズミでした〜
この大きさで200円。マジふざけんn
2つ目いきましょう
あ、待って
これも小さいんだけど
ちょ、まさか
ちょ、ちょいちょいちょい
アァァァァァァァァァアア！！！！
うぉっほ
やばい、１番被ってはいけないようなところが被ってしまった
可愛いね
やばい、このサイズで200円でしょ
ちょっと焦ってきました
残り4つです開けていきましょう
はっは、待って
これも小さい
先にこっち開けようか
これ小さいよ、待って待ってやばいやばいやばい
はっ、違う！ハリネズミじゃない！
はっ！
わぁ！うさぎさんが出ました〜
しゃくれてます
ハリネズミと比べてもちょっと大きいです
これ3つで600円です
（グサッ）
あと3つが大きいから多分いける気がするぞ〜
４つ目です
これは大きい
重さ的に
はぁ！！！
はっはっはっはwww
コイツに関しては正面から見てもちょっとブサイクだなぁ
横から見たらこんな感じです
この子たちちょっと笑ってるんです実は
なんて顔してんだマジで
前回のライオンさんとサイズ感が凄い似てるね
これ友達だな
わ、凄いなだいぶ数が増えてきたぞ〜
じゃあ残り2つです、開けていきましょう！
いやぁちょっとこれ以上被って欲しくない、いきます！
はい！！
はああ！でかい！！！
分かれてる分かれてる！！
これはもう組み合わせないと作れないやつですね
はい、できました！
これはクジラですね
はっはっはっはwww
これは凄いぞ
はっはっはっはっはっはwww
でっかっw
では次でラストでございます
最後の１個くらいちょっと出てないのが出て欲しいですねぇ
いきます！
頼む！ラスト１個出てないのが出てくれ！
はっ！！！！！
出たぁ！！新しいのだ！！！
は！
はっはっはっはっはっはっはww
うぉっほっほっっほww
過去最大級にしゃくれてますね
バッファローですね
最後の一人がしゃくれたバッファローでしたw
こいつが１番たち悪いッッnク
ン・・・ック・・
うわっ！！！！ハァハァハァハァ
なんだ今のは
（ワウううう）
うわぁぁ！！！
（ワウ）
と、トミックさんwww
（ワウ、ガウガウ）
この前と同様！
アゴがしゃくれているから乗り移ってしまったのかぁ！！！wwww
(agars)
うわぁ！！(agars)